Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
So continuing in the narration of Abbass
regarding the story of the rebuilding of
the Kaa. Of course we are reading this
taken from real
and the 18th book. So second to last
book the book of almanat
the book of miscellaneous and general
stories
and
99%
of all that I speak of especially after
isha
I try to always take from
why because you all have access to it
everyone has access to the Elder Salen.
And everyone is highly encouraged to
always
go back home, read these things,
reread them, review them. As a matter of
fact,
is a book that everyone should have
right on their nightstand as soon as
they wake up in the morning. Give it a
half an hour
along with your portion of Quran that
you recite. And every night before you
go to sleep, you read as well of
now we discussed up until the part where
Ibraimis
came back to visit his son is after he
had grown up.
Now,
as we mentioned this particular wording
of the narration,
if you were to only take this wording,
it would seem
that Ibraim
left
and is when is an infant and came back
after is had already grown up and gotten
married.
And this narration doesn't mention any
visits in between. So a question a
question may occur a person may ask does
this mean that Ibraim never visited his
son Ismael
in the entire time until he grew up? The
answer is of course not he visited
often.
And in the Quran, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala tells us in
that Ibraim was commanded to slaughter
his son is when he was a young boy. So
he was above the age of a toddler under
the age of puberty, right?
And there are a number of narrations
addresses this in his book
and he mentions a narration on the
authority of
reported by that
used to visit
at least once a month on bak.
The same bak that
our prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam used to travel from Mecca to
to Alah and Ibraim was living where at
that time
in Hashem around Aar which is so poetic
right because it really ties up
everything at the end. Imagine Ibraim
comes out here to the middle of this
desert in Mecca. He leaves his offspring
to Allah. He goes back to Hashem. He
comes and visits on Alak. And then
finally
the the fruit of his offspring.
[Arabic recitation]
back on the same bak to al
and then he climbs into the heavens and
meets Ibraimisam.
Incredibly poetic. And so the point here
is that Ibraim came back the first time
he found his wife there and and is out
hunting and she didn't know who he was.
and you know he asked about his mim.
She said, "Well, he's out hunting and he
said,"Well, how are you guys living?"
Now, mind you, he's a stranger to her,
right? He doesn't she doesn't know who
he is.
And she starts to complain.
Oh, we're living so tough. Things are
hard. you know, we're living so you
know, we're living in in hardship, etc.
And and Ibraim
is listening.
And then after this, he tells her
when is returns, tell him I said salam
and tell him I said to change the
threshold to his home.
And then he left and is returned. He
says, "Did anybody come looking for me
today?" She said, "Yes, as a matter of
fact, an elderly man, but he was very
well put together. He came asking about
you." He said, "Well,
what did he what did he say?" Well, he
asked how we were living. And I told him
that we were living tough. I told him
the truth, right? This is this is how I
told him the truth. I said how it was,
right? because this is not something
that if she's complaining to a stranger,
she's obviously complained to her
husband before. And he said, "Did did
she say did he say anything more?" She
said, "Yes." He said, "To say a sadm to
you and to change your threshold." He
said, "That's my father and you are the
threshold and he has commanded me to
divorce you and part ways with you."
Now if we take a stop here we see that
what is the point here of this
narration? Why is the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam telling us
about this
the threshold? Think of that think of
that
analogy that he's giving.
The wife is the threshold of his home.
She represents his home. She is his
first impression to his home.
And this threshold needs repair. It is
not appropriate for a messenger, the son
of a messenger.
And so he divorces her. He marries
again. Ibraim
returns again. Is not there.
And he asks how they are living. She
doesn't know Ibraim. She says,
"Alhamdulillah,
we are living well in Allah's grace,
etc."
And he asked her, "What do you
predominantly eat
here in this land?" She said, "We eat
predominantly
alle
meat,
predominantly meat and water.
And Ibraimisam
made dua for the meat and water and all
of their diets at that time. Our prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam said at that time
because the city of Mecca was still just
a little village and it had not grown to
the point where it can import yet. They
did not eat and they did not have a
steady importation of you know things
beans and wheat and grains and so
forth. So Ibraim made dua for what they
had. The prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam tells us that one of the
specifics of Mecca
is that its meat and its water
particularly
are mubarak in Mecca.
What would take two portions to fill you
up outside of Mecca will take only one
in Mecca because of the dua of Ibraim.
Now this woman when she was asked she
focused on which part of the glass the
glass is half full the glass half empty.
We know this right? The the analogy of
pessimism and optimism right? The
optimist looks at the half full part of
the glass. They describe the same glass
as half full. And the cynical, the
cynicist or the pessimist will describe
the glass as half empty. Correct?
Now in Islam, what are we taught? We are
taught to always focus on the good. And
if our eye ever starts to stray from the
blessing of Allah, we are always to look
to those who are more fortunate or less
fortunate.
less fortunate.
Listen to what our prophet sallall.aii
wasallam says.
He says
he says that
I lost my train of thought. He says man
[Silence]
He says that if a person
rises in the morning
safe,
healthy and has enough food and water
for that day, it is as if the entirety
of the dunya has been rolled up and
placed at his feet.
What more could you ask? And the prophet
Sam
says in Muslim,
[Silence]
he said, "Always look to those who are
less fortunate than yourselves
and never look
longing to those who are more fortunate
than yourselves.
Because if you practice this, it is more
likely that you will not belittle the
blessing of Allah upon you. You got
problems, tell me your problems and I'll
produce a man that has twice those
problems. And if he tells me his
problems, I'll produce another that has
twice his problems and so forth. You
have one leg, I'll bring you a man that
has no legs. You have no legs, I'll
bring you a man that has no legs and no
hands. You have no legs and hands, I'll
hands and no eyes. And so it goes.
Everyone
is faced with half empty and half full
glass. Everyone.
We are to hyperfocus
on the half full. Hyperfocus. This is
not something that's natural. Human
beings don't naturally do this. Human
beings naturally are negative creatures.
Do you know why humans are so negative?
Why they are so naturally pessimistic?
Why humans are so naturally cynical? Do
you know why? Because of fear.
Fear
is what drives our cynicism.
We want things to be better, better,
better because we are so afraid because
we are surrounded by death and
misfortune.
And so optimism,
being optimistic,
looking at the half full part of the
glass, this is driven by courage.
hyperfocusing on the half empty part of
the glass. This is driven by cowardice.
And so my brothers and my sisters, this
goes for everything. This is across the
board. This is not just on your
clothing, your well-being, your
livelihood, your life, also your spouse.
This is something you have to train
yourself to do. When you get married,
you're going to start to be introduced
to another human being that has good
qualities and bad qualities.
Every human being has good qualities.
Everyone
had good qualities, did he not?
Of course he does. Pure evil, it doesn't
exist. Even El has good qualities
somewhere. I'm sure he raises his
children and tells them he loves them
and all these things. Every every living
creature has negative and positive, has
an element of evil and good.
When you are introduced to this spouse,
you're going to start to see negative
things. You're going to start to see
positive things. Listen to what your
prophet tells you. You want to keep your
marriage together. Listen to what he
says. He says,
for
[Silence]
in the narration of
the prophet sallall.aii Wasam said, "No
believer,
no believing man is ever to hate any
believing woman. If he dislikes
some aspect of her character, he needs
to look for an aspect of her character
that he admires." This goes for men and
women. And this is a conscious effort
that you do right away, not in the long
run, not tomorrow. When you're angry
with your spouse, when you see something
that you hate,
immediately you need to train yourself
to think of something that you to
counter this thing that you hate.
Right? I hate that my husband leaves the
towels on the ground after he comes out
of the shower. I hate it. Well, say
that. Alhamdulillah. But he does do this
over here, right? He doesn't leave hair
in the sink. Whatever. This is just a a
silly a silly example. But the point
is is that we always have to force our
eyes to look back at the good.
Otherwise, you become hyperfocused on
the bad and a messenger of Allah would
advise your spouse to change you out.
Yeah. Imagine yourself. Imagine
Ibraimisam
came to visit your home. What would he
tell your spouse?
What message would he tell you to give
your wife? What message would he tell
you to give your husband? This is very
important especially for our sisters.
What is the message that Ibraim would
tell you to tell your husband?
keep the threshold or change the
threshold.
It's something you have to be honest
about.
And if you're honest, this is when you
will become better. You know, if we sit
around non-Muslims all the time and we
breathe their air and we we start to get
infected with the way that they look at
the world,
it's not okay for us to just kind of
passively say, "Well, you know, Muslim,
non-Muslim, you know, everybody's
trying. What's the big deal?" No, no.
There could never be a bigger difference
between a true Muslim and a non-Muslim.
They are so stark opposites.
And if you sit too long and it and and
and
you know subject yourself to their
way of seeing the world, you'll start to
see the world in the same way. And what
is that? A stomach that can never be
satisfied
private parts that will never be
quelled.
Allah says about those who disbelieve in
Allah,
Allah says leave them to eat
and play
and be sidetracked and distracted with
hopes and dreams. This is the world that
they live in. So the Muslim starts to
learn.
sister goes on Tik Tok, goes on
Facebook or face whatever it is, she
sees a video of someone that says, "You
know, the way I see the world, when my
husband does this, I say this, and this
is what I think about this. Who is this
person?" Allah, she could have just
crawled out of hell right now and gotten
a cell phone and started talking. We
don't know who it is, but it sounds good
at the moment.
But the sister's strong enough to reject
that. Then the second one and the third
video and the fourth video and the first
month and the second month and the third
month and you start to learn how to only
look at bad things around you. That
truly is the epitome of punishment from
Allah. That's your own personal hell.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam he says
for
[Silence]
Listen
to these two things. We'll end with
this.
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam says
that whoever's focus is the hereafter.
Allah will make his affairs orderly
and he will place his wealth in his
heart for him
and the dunya will come to him to his
feet in spite of itself
and whoever's hyperfocus is this dunya
Allah will make his affairs scattered
and he will place his poverty right in
front of his eyes. Everywhere he looks,
he can only see his poverty. He can't
see anything that is good. All he can
see is what he wishes he had. He looks
at his children, he wishes someone
else's children. He looks at his cars,
he wishes a different car. He looks at
his house, he wishes a different house.
Looks at his wife, wishes a different
wife. Looks at his masid, wishes a
different masid. Looks at his shoes,
wish This is a disease,
he says.
And the only thing that will come to him
after all of that of the dunya is what
Allah had already written for him.
Nothing more. You're straining yourself.
And at the end, you know what? You get
only what Allah wrote 50,000 years
before the creation.
And we always talk about the grass is
greener on the other side. You want to
hear a story? Very quick story. You'll
this story. I know we go a little
bit over time, but I see everyone is
listening.
Very quick story.
So
in 2013
or 2012 thereabouts,
there was a man and a woman that were
married in Bosnia,
Muslim,
and they started to grow apart. They're
married, but you know what they say, we
grew apart. No, no, no. You grew bored.
That's what happened. It's not a part.
It's boredom. And so they got bored with
each other. So the man went on a dating
app trying to find another wife.
And the wife went on a dating app trying
to find another husband.
You know what her handle was?
Huh? Bosnian Princess. This is the
psychology we're dealing with here.
And so Bosnian princess jumps on the
internet and
some what do they say? Some some guy
some suitor
slides into her DMs, right?
So she's talking now to this guy and
this guy is perfect.
This guy is everything she wanted.
and
he started to hook up with another girl
on the internet. And this girl is
everything he wanted. Now, notice what's
happening here.
He's in one room chatting with a woman
that he is not married to and finding
his solace and complaining to her about
his wife.
She's in another room talking to some
strange man complaining about her
husband.
They're in the bed physically together,
but separately they couldn't be more
separate.
And so one day the time comes for our
Bosnian princess to go meet Mr. Perfect.
a few months later. It was two or three
months.
And so they are to meet in some park or
some place.
She gives him an excuse. I have to go
wherever. You know, she's not telling
her husband she's going to meet another
man. She gives some excuse to go.
And when they go to meet, who is there
waiting for her at the park?
her husband.
You can't make this stuff up. It writes
itself.
They had no idea that this whole time
they were talking to each other.
The whole time he thought he was talking
to Bosnian princess and Bosnian princess
thought she was talking to Mr. Perfect.
And actually they were talking to each
other, complaining to each other about
each other.
Now if this happened to you, what lesson
would you derive from this? I mean the
lesson almost forces itself. It could
not be any more clear, any more on the
nose that everything that you need is
potentially there in your wife.
Everything that you need is potentially
in your husband.
Did they look at this and
thinkahillahill,
what am I to learn from this? You know
what happened two months later? They
filed for divorce.
You know what they filed on their
divorce papers?
That they cheated on each other. He said
that he she cheated on him. She said he
cheated on her. Irreconcilable
differences. This is a true story.
This really just kind of captures the
essence of the human nature.
If a human being had a valley of gold,
he'd wish there were two.
A wife can make herself everything her
husband wants.
She has to desire to do that.
And a woman can see everything she wants
in her husband. She has to make herself
do this. And a man and his wife. This is
possible. When you are upset with your
spouse, you see something that think
back to when you first met, how excited
you were and all the butterflies in your
stomach and how you couldn't wait for
this person to speak to you. That's
still the same person. The same person
you were excited about is still the same
person. It didn't change. You just
learned other things. Do not confuse
boredom
with
you know do not confuse boredom with
falling out of love.
Usually our
Saturday or Friday talks after are just
about 10 minutes but we went a little
bit over today for the sake of the
occasion
and inshallah we will continue this
narration tomorrow evening.
You know, Muhammad